IBS scores are powerful tools that can give
you a sense of genetic identity, with other humans
around you. But it's not just the presence
of similar SNVs that gives away clues to relatedness
but, it's also the order of the SNVs.
Remember when personal genetic information is obtained, not only
is the individual SNV determined, but we know where
exactly it's placement is on the Chromosome. This order
on the chromosome is significant, when we consider that
your genome is one set of chromosomes from one parent
and one set of chromosomes from another. What if instead
of doing a point by point comparison of SNV's, we
actually look at the order in which you share
them along the length of a chromosome. For example lets
say you find that your 50% related to one individual.
Now this is not 50% IBS. Okay, this is not
what we're talking about. We're talking about relatedness you're
50% or half related to someone. In the genetics
world there are only two options that allow you
to be half. Exactly half related to someone. You're half
related to a Parent. Right? You have two parents.
You receive half your chromosomes from one and half
from another. And you're also half related to one
of your Full Siblings. So based on what you know
about chromosome transmission and recombination which we
learned about in lesson five. Which of the
following chromosome comparison diagrams indicates a parental
relationship and which one indicates a full sibling
relationship? Now in this particular scenario the
shaded areas are whole links of shared SNVs.
So there is were we had an IBS match. These SNVs match with the other person.
Remember you have two copies of every chromosome so
imagine that these are your chromosomes. And in this
scenario, you match them with an individual, and you
see the shaded regions are shared. You match with another
individual, and you see that the shaded region is
shared here along the length of the whole chromosome,
but not the other. Indicate which one is the
parental relationship and which one is the full sibling relationship.
By entering the number one or the number two in the text boxes you see here.